[Music]
there was the woman's Marsh then hashtag
day without immigrants not to be outdone
the feminists came roaring back with
hashtag day without a woman on March 8
it was publicized everywhere all over
media new media Facebook front page of
YouTube after it started taking place
however there was no mention of it
thankfully me and my producer went down
to the protest and what do we find well
a very small group of slightly large
nonsensical young women who really just
wanted in the name of equality
everything we also do call for full
reproductive rights including completely
free equity abortion you know these are
things that we call for because sure
abortion is not just the only machine
with abortion as a transaction for sure
a man with you of course intimacy that's
an international issue to legislate
against one [ __ ] and tell them what they
pay McCain on suspended that sounds just
like the previous women's March so what
made this one different we're kind of
ditching the capitalism the
heteronormativity
okay the transphobia the six suspects
ISM that was so rampant with the winning
smart right we're going into something
more more interception alluring Cupid
okay that was an argument more radical
plan have it all but there's an
exploiting caught in an exploited class
class so environmental justice to
reproductive justice and environmental
justice system animus you probably
borrow from a comrade Cobra yeah is that
what happened bring a glass ceiling if
it needs to chart for billions of we
women that are home welcome Stepan near
the truth in matters even when I'm
talking right now this is unpaid labor
you know I support you recognize me sure
casein that we do in the
unpaid labor it still begs the question
what does any of this have to do with
feminism and as far as event attendance
big swing in a minute
as you know revolutionary socialists who
are many of the people organizing this
and we're not here to promote this next
cousin Moorhead are known to be sure
especially if they're about feminism
which is not about biological
determinism in offenses of a join us
because you're not only at that image
detrimental to people who don't have
that Anatomy or people who are concerned
Adam I'm not sure that exactly that's
right also pink and not everybody has
paints in Italia you know it is it was
very much just a white woman's life okay
what's happening here is Oh crazy blue
haired feminist was wondering when you'd
show we have a Nazi that's going that is
going is supporting what's coming up
here I'm not open white supremacists in
office now and truthfully like who uh
you've been in my boss she's an open
white supremacist yes really Nazi or
fanic
okay okay we're back okay Anna so what
is there specific reasons for the red so
the red actually historically women's
day was a day is national actions of
socialistic short and so we decide to
wear red in solidarity that is read like
an official socialist party color or is
it it's late okay so kind of like the
communism sort of read yeah okay so an
offshoot communism Lenin approves love
the speech are you one struggling
teaching today actually I'm not a
teacher this semester but I am
definitely checking from helping other
faculty at a women's university okay
you probably be I don't know striking
and I kick at thank you very much
because I'm a pirate carpet pirate this
and we do things much different okay but
you're not teaching this semester I am
NOT and if you were you wouldn't be
today you better believe it
okay well this event on this campus was
very small and somewhat depressing but
we were assured that there would be
hundred later on at the town square and
the next campus over would be much
bigger with a lot more going on so we
decided to check that out so what you
want
Nerissa most until we know what's going
on here sure you can point that like in
Jaws erection he can sure you can point
never and like when it in not sure what
we're just doing right there he's
following I really I ask not to point to
them no he's playing it at me though
we're doing a documentary I don't know
why this school contention I said on the
other lucky and then which may be or
could be on it but that's not what
you're doing again is actually really
alienating everyone here really I owned
the video I don't see anyone else here
it's really upset you don't need it and
if you don't want to speak with that
because you're uncomfortable that's the
way I was I get it I get it I get it
you're uncomfortable okay don't film
then we're just an easy okay that's fine
you can do simple III ask you not to be
wanted he's filming me this guy was
clearly triggered so we decided to leave
sorry please not you not to look he's
back now thanks for doing it sorry we
met you're uncomfortable okay if and
it's not it's not new to us not new to
us with you being uncomfortable that's
okay we understand it we respect it you
need your space Oh skunked again that
only left us with the march on down to
town square it was time to let their
freak flag fly all 14 of them
[Music]
that was a who this is to whom she's
referring he was not a white supremacist
matter-of-factly the mud club member
told me he likes my red outfit oh he's
probably mean an ass he's a white
supremacist yeah so you someone
recognize you yeah your progra got okay
yeah they're just like you know you know
you need to go to the back
oh oh that type of debt oh what's the
killing of black trans women so like the
majority of like violence committed
against like like like trans people and
trans men particularly are like targeted
for like like a lot like it's like in
terms of like police violence and just
like intimate partner violence and like
a lot of them like I'm going to say a
lot of them but there are like result
significant part of the train population
that's like that are sex workers and
they're like Orson the sex work
oftentimes because like they don't have
any avenues for employment as employment
discrimination yeah I mean am i right
so one of those things have come yeah I
think we've all had that yeah so like
oftentimes they're like targeted for
like I was like like violence off like
there's a lot there's this thing it's
like that's why you call yours are you
anything right yeah what are they doing
like so like trans load of color and
particularly like black trans women are
often the ones that like the most like
likely to be targeted for like park
lights violent places like a murder
scene things okay so it's like a
particular issue like I think that then
trans people have been murdered so far
this year like and the trans population
is not big there's a huge week at um not
only from white women to white males but
also like Asian America movement
women right all getting paid 75 cents 55
cents
45 cents is what I think Lana
communicates to the dollars Shibata good
little bugs or of them were trans women
like we're black trans women
specifically so okay it like definitely
like personally speaking like share is
significant significant issue like it's
just like it's like an intersection of
like white supremacy in like trains oh
yeah
that's unbelievable but seven murders -
so we didn't get to taste through the
whole thing because well it was a little
long and boring
there was nothing interesting about that
the most telling thing to me know what
it had literally like nothing to do with
feminism very little comrade socialist
communism blah abortion on hand period a
period and Union is very little to do
with women's right um also very few
people and that one daughter was a white
supremacist that thought barking at one
of the colored folks he was
dusting and Franklin so it didn't really
have a whole lot to do with feminism and
well come back and we'll talk about it
again at a time high
that was a crock --is-- wasn't it if you
like this video subscribe by clicking
the button that says subscribe if you're
not aware of it now there's no way
you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped for my daily show available
exclusively to Lata with credit calm /
mug club members of your student
military or veteran entering that promo
code it's less than $6 a month and you
get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand edge mug oh I just when I feel
it I got a chill like on the inside